hello my name is tiana martinez i am a
postdoc
at the fred hutchinson cancer research
center today i will tell you about
checkpoint blockchain induced thought
immunity
lessons from ross models of type 1
diabetes and this work that i'll be
presenting is the work i have done as a
graduate student
at the university of minnesota in the
laboratory of dr brian fife
but before i begin and get into the
specifics of my project
i would like to give you a brief outline
of what i'll be discussing today
first i will introduce the program that
one or pd1 signaling pathway
then i will explain the clinical
benefits and challenges
associated with pd1 checkpoint blockade
i will next describe the role of pd1
in most models of diabetes and i'll
present our data
and i will close by highlighting the
ongoing efforts to develop reliable mark
biomarkers
for safe and effective use of pd1
blockade
program.1 or pd1 is expressed on diesel
surface
24 to 48 hours after energy recognition
pd1 can bind to ligands pdl1 or pdl2
and deliver an inhibitory signal to the
t cell
this results in reduced t cell target
cell contact time
reduce cytotoxicity and cytokine
production as well as reduce
t cell proliferation and survival
overall pd1 is an immune checkpoint that
maintains immune homeostasis
so that t cells do not cause
immunopathology however
tumor cells exploit the pd1 pathway and
they express high levels of pdl1
in addition tumor infiltrating t cells
express high levels of pd-1
and this continuous pd-1pl1 signaling
interaction
drives progressive t-cell dysfunction or
exhaustion
pd-1 checkpoint blockade has been shown
to restore
tumor control in mice and these
fantastic responses
together with responses seen when
another
immune checkpoint is blocked really led
to development
of clinical inhibitors of pd1 and pdl
signaling
the very first clinical studies showed
staggering responses
in patients with melanoma and prompted
further development in testing
so currently pd1 and pdl1 checkpoint
blockade
is used to treat over 15 different
malignancies and the response rates are
quite encouraging
as you can see here in this table for
example about 40 percent
of melanoma patients respond favorably
to p1 blockade
whereas almost 90 percent of patients
with hodgkin's disease benefit
so this is very exciting what challenges
remain
most notably some patients and some
tumor types remain
poorly responsive to treatment blockade
and this is known as primary resistance
only about fourteen percent of all
cancer patients in the united states
are benefiting from checkpoint blockade
and this may not seem like a lot
but only five percent of all cancer
patients benefit from molecularly
targeted therapies
so checkpoint blockade is clearly
pushing the envelope but there's still
more work to be done
besides primary resistance secondary
resistance
is another issue in that a fraction of
patients
relapse after therapy and finally a
subset of patients develop
immune related adverse events or even
overtaught immunity
and as you can see from this figure this
type of adverse event can affect
virtually any organ system
so to safely and effectively use
checkpoint blockade
we must identify biomarkers that could
distinguish responders from
non-responders
design therapies to overcome resistance
and develop biomarkers that could
identify people
at risk of serious adverse events there
has been quite a bit of progress
in identifying these biomarkers that
could distinguish responders and
non-responders
and probably the most notable biomarker
is pre-existence
of t-cell infiltration cold tumors
such as those that do not have
considerable t-cell infiltrate
do not respond well to pediatric
blockade whereas hot tumors which are
those that
do have a substantial disorder before
treatment
respond favorably to this type of
therapy
it is becoming clear that t cell
function is governed by
not only pd1 or ctlf4 but by other
inhibitory inactivating receptors so
dual
inhibitory or activating receptor
targeting
might be able to overcome resistance and
current clinical trials are designed to
test
specifically that additionally
checkpoint blockade is
combined with radiation therapy or
chemotherapy in an effort to benefit
more patients and overcome both primary
and secondary resistance
now in terms of biomarkers that predict
adverse events
a recent work has shown that changes in
peripheral b cells and specifically an
increase in
antibody producing plasma cells can
correlate with the development of
adverse events
and i will touch on this later during my
talk
but really what we're trying to
accomplish with pd1 truck on blockade
is we're trying to unleash cancer
specific t cells
and lyses them to kill tumor cells but
because pd1 can be expressed by a
variety of t-cells
we might be unleashing self-specific
t-cells
when we administer this therapy and
therefore causing damage to healthy
cells and tissues
and leading to development of
immune-related adverse events
as i mentioned previously these adverse
events can manifest in a variety of
organs
and they can also range from amount to
severe it seems like their incidence
correlates with responsive therapy in
other words
patients who develop adverse events are
likely the ones who are also responding
to therapy
and experiencing tumor shrinkage or
stable disease
but i want to i want to highlight that
some of these advertisements can be
quite serious
and involve overt autoimmunity such as
type 1 diabetes
type 1 diabetes has been shown to
develop in up to 3
of patients treated with pd1 or pm1
blocking antibodies
and although that might not seem like a
lot there are over 2 000
active clinical trials right now testing
premature on blockade
with an estimated enrollment of half a
million patients
so this may be a serious concern going
forward
in the fife lab at the university of
minnesota we were interested in how does
pd1 regulate
cell specific tnp cells in type 1
diabetes
so to answer this question we use
non-obese diabetic or non-mice to
develop diabetes spontaneously as you
can see
in this disease curve non-mice develop
diabetes even more quickly if they lack
pd1
i also want to point out that cd4 and
cdft cells as well as b
cells are absolutely required for kappa
division onset in these animals
but it seems like cd40 cells are playing
a critical role
because mhc class 2 or hla class 2
alleles
are specifically conferring the highest
genetic risk
for typing diabetes development another
point i want to make
is that insulin is a major auto antigen
in typo diabetes in mice as well as in
humans
in fact almost all patients who are
diagnosed before five years of age
have detectable insulin-specific or
antibodies suggesting that this breach
in insulin tolerance
in the b cell compartment as well as in
c4t cells
seems to drive disease
so before i explain how we think pd1
regulates b-cell and c-4 t-cell
interactions
i will first walk you through what these
interactions look like
b-cells and t cells interact within the
journal center region on the lymph node
terminal center b cells take up antigen
processed and presented
in the context of mhc class 2. this
allows
them to interact with
c4t cells that have this t-follicular
helper or tfh phenotype
tfh cells provide l4 l21 and city 40
ligand stimulation
to trigger somatic hypermutation and
production of high affinity antibodies
by this journal center b cells
at the same time another subset of t
cells
is working to basically dampen this
reaction
these cells are known as t follicular
regulatory cells and they
express il-10 and also rely on ctla4
to reduce this amount of city for t cell
help
all in all germinal center b cells can
acquire two specific fates after
receiving help from t cells they can
either become memory b cells
or plasma cells that are poised to
secrete high infant in the antibodies
i really want to highlight that this
balance of t follicular helper in
regulatory cells
is critical there is
a significant increase in t follicular
helper cells in patients without
immunity including those with type 1
diabetes
in studies in mice options the
conditional deletion of tfr cells
directly leads to autoimmunity
i also want to highlight that pd1 or
pdl1
are expressed by essentially all cells
in the general center
germinal center b cells tfh and tfr
cells all express pd1
whereas journal center b cells can
express pdl1 or pdl2
so it is very likely that this pathway
is playing a role in controlling the
celta cell interaction
it has been known for a while that pd1
deficiency promotes
other antibody production in b6 and in
balsami mice
however subsequent studies have found
contradictory results
several studies have shown that p1
deficiency impairs the journal center
whereas others have shown the p1
deficiency enhances the journal center
and leads to better antibody production
in the context of infection
work done at harvard in the lab of dr
arlene sharp has shown that pd1
deficiency our blockade
affects both tfh and tfr cells and that
the relative ratios of these cell types
end up determining the outcome of the
journal center reaction
so to examine how pd1 regulates b cell
and safe for t cell interactions in type
1 diabetes
we developed tetramer reagents that
allowed us to track
insulin-specific c4 t-cells these
tetramer regions are four-pronged
soluble ligands of the t-cell receptor
they incorporate insulin peptide in the
context of mrc class two
which is biatimulated and conjugated to
fluorescently label streptavidin
this allows us to track these cells by
flow cytometry
we also developed insulin tetramers to
track insulin-specific b-cells
these reagents incorporate biotinylated
insulin that is conjugated to
streptavidin
and fluorescent labels
using these reagents we were able to
enumerate and phenotype
insulin-specific lymphocytes in
wild-type numbers as well as those that
lack pd-1 or pdl-1
we also evaluated the effects of p1 plot
by blockade in diabetes prone and
diabetes resistant mice
and i will i'll be sharing some of those
data with you today
first we examine whether insulin
specific cd4 t cells express
pd1 and what you can see in this graph
is that as
non-mice age and approach diabetes onset
there's an increase in the proportion of
cells that is pd1 positive
in the pancreas all insulin specificity
for t cells express p1
and what is very interesting is that the
amount of pd1 expression
correlates with how brightly these cells
are staining with our tetramer reagent
in other words those insulin-specific
cells that have the highest affinity for
antigen
or the highest autoimmune potential
expressed the most p1
we next text tested the effect of pd1
blockade on this cell type
what you can see in this graph is that
detroit positive
cf14 cells increase the number after pd1
treatment
when we look at the phenotype of these
cells we can see that
there is a significant increase in
insulin-specific cd14 cells that have
this tfh phenotype that are poised
to help b cells create our antibodies
we calculated the ratio of tfh and t for
our cells and saw that it was skewed
in favor of t follicular helper cells
dramatically after pediment blockade
so this prompted us to look and examine
what is the phenotype limits on specific
b cells
what i'm showing you here is the number
of insulin-specific b-cells
at various standpoints after feeding
more treatment in non-waste
and you can see that p1 blockade
increased significantly the number of
v-cells at all tested time points
what is also important is that the
phenotype of these cells was different
we observed a significant increase in
germinal center b cells that were
installed specific
and we also saw a trend towards
increased insulin-specific plasma cells
so cells that produce antibodies
when we examine antibodies in the serum
of treated non-mice
we saw a significant increase suggesting
that pd1 blockade
unleashed insulin or antibody production
this was in parallel with increased
allen inflammation
what you can see in this graph is that
after antipediment treatment
about 50 percent of violets in the
pancreas were severely inflamed
as opposed to only about 10 percent of
violets in control animals
because antipedia one treatment
ultimately leads to typo diabetes onset
and inflammation
we wanted to make sure that the effects
we were seeing in the adrenal
center were due to cell intrinsic
pitimer signaling
so to test that we set up mixed bomber
cameras
we sublethally irradiated non-mice and
we reconstituted them with a 50-50 mix
of wild type and pity monaco bone marrow
cells
we let these mice reconstitute and we
harvested them six to eight weeks later
and examined their t-cell repertoire
what you can see here is that is the
number of insulin-specific c4t cells in
the thymus
and specifically the number of cells
that originate from the wild type or the
pd1 deficient
donor you can see there's really no
difference suggesting that these cells
are developing
at about the same rate but if we look in
the periphery
you see that pd1 knockout cells are now
out competing
the wild type cells and specifically if
we look at
insulin-specific tfh cells or tfr cells
you can see that almost all of them are
derived from the p1 deficient
donor so these results suggest that cell
intrinsic loss of pd1
promotes tfhc for t cell generation
we next wanted to examine whether
blocking this cd4 t cell and b cell
interaction
can reduce the effects of antipediam1
and to accomplish this we developed a
monoclonal antibody
that blocks insulin peptide presentation
in the context of mhc class 2.
so when we treated mice with antipedia1
we again observed this robust increase
in the number of insulin-specific b
cells in the pancreatic left bone but
when we treated mice with antipedia1
and with our monoclonal antibody insulin
4g8
we saw a reduction so antipediment did
not
so dramatically increase the number of
b-cells when we
use combination therapy
additionally when we looked in the
pancreas we saw the fewer highlights
were severely infiltrated in the case of
combination therapy
so this results would suggest that a
similar approach could be used in the
clinic
to mitigate some of the off-target
effects of antipd1
so to summarize these findings what i've
shown you so far is that in non-mice p1
blockade
leads to an increase in insulin-specific
tfh cells
in some specific germinal center b cells
and insulin-specific other antibodies
and this seems to correlate with typo
debilitate
i don't have time to show you these data
but we observed similar findings
in non-mysterac pd1 or pdl1
but when we performed these studies and
used an antipedial two blocking antibody
we saw no change in the dermal cell
reaction and no
change in insulin or antibodies so this
really suggests
that pd1 and pdl1 interaction and not
pd1 and pdl2
are regulating the general center
we've also shown that blocking insulin
peptide and mhc complex recognition
visiting for t cells using this
monoclonal antibody
can reduce some of the effects of
antipedian1 and
a similar strategy might be beneficial
in the clinic
so again to address how pd1 regulates b
cell
for t-cell interactions in type 1
diabetes we also wanted to examine
a strain of mice that is typical
division resistant
so to descend we use b6 ig-7 mice
that express the same mhc class 2
molecule as non-mice
and again as a reminder this predisposes
them to type on diabetes risk
but these mice remain diabetes free
we have previously shown that b6 ig7
might have a pool of naive
insulin-specific cd4 t cells and
periphery and now we wanted to test
whether p1 blockade
changes the phenotype of these cells or
promotes or antibody production
what you can see in this graph is that
after antipediamond treatment in b6ig7
mice
we did not detect a significant change
in insulin-specific city 40 cell members
we also did not affect the change in
their phenotype we did not observe an
increase
in tfh cells looking at its own specific
b cells
in these mice we also did not observe a
difference
and finally there was no change in
insulin or antibodies
after pm1 blockade in b6 ig7 mice
so to summarize our data from autoimmune
prone and autoimmune resistant mice
it seems like there's a requirement for
pre-activated tmb
cells for entity one treatment to lead
to type 1 diabetes
in b6i g7 mice there are virtually no
activated cell specific tmb cells so
antipediama treatment does not
precipitate
type 1 diabetes but in non-mice there is
already a subclinical autoimmune
response
there are already detectable cell
specific dnb cells that are activated
and so antipedia 1 is further unleashing
them
and precipitating rapid type 1 diabetes
offset
so what does this mean for the clinic
well it has been shown that people who
develop type 1 diabetes after pd1 or
pdl1 checkpoint blockade
are more likely to carry hla alleles
that are associated with type 1 diabetes
risk
in humans these are dr3 and therefore
it has also been shown that a subset of
people who develop type 1 diabetes
after pd1 blockade have pre-existing
ntla antibodies or pre-existing
subclinical
autoimmune reactivity and again this is
in line with our findings
a separate study looking at patients who
developed pituitary gland or lung
inflammation after checkpoint blockade
found pre-existing pool of water
antibodies that target subproteins
again this is in line with our findings
and most models as well
so to summarize pd1 checkpoint black kid
has revolutionized cancer therapy
but not all patients benefit primary
resistance relapsed after therapy and
development of adverse events following
triple blockade
are emerging as main challenges there
has been enormous progress in
identifying biomarkers that stratify
patients who likely benefit from
painting one blockade
combination therapy approaches including
those that target t cell activating
receptors or more than one t cell
inhibitor receptor
are likely to reduce both primary and
secondary resistance
our working mass models of varying type
of diabetes susceptibilities
such as that pre-existing activated cd4
t cells and b cells are required for
autoimmunity development
after feeding a checkpoint blockade
in recent clinical studies identified
specific quarter antibodies whose
emergence
pre or during checkpoint blockade
correlates with the development of these
adverse events
so we proposed that hla testing and
screening
for common auto antibodies before
therapy administration
might guide therapy selection or
mitigate these adverse cements
of checkpoint blockade so with that
i would like to thank my colleagues at
the university of minnesota specifically
dr brian fife who was my mentor during
graduate work i would also like to thank
my colleagues at the fred hutch
everyone in the greenberg lab and
especially dr phil greenberg for his
outstanding mentorship
thank you for your attention and thank
you for the opportunity to present my
work